ces images ont provoqué un véritable
tollé dans toute l'espagne
dès la fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
dimanche à minuit des centaines de
jeunes se sont agglutinés dans les rues
majoritairement sans masque et avec un
objectif faire la fête
on est venu voir l'ambiance et on dirait
un peu le nouvel an on attend minuit
pour pouvoir aller dans la rue et voir
s'il ya beaucoup de gens au pas
visiblement il y a beaucoup de jeunes
qui font la fête
c'est incroyable cela fait tellement
longtemps que nous devons nous confiner
dans des endroits tout petit comme des
appartements ou des maisons
vous savez les gens continuent à faire
la fête tous les jours nous faisons
toujours la fête mais différemment
maintenant danser chanter et profitez
alors que les hôpitaux restent à flux
tendu les vidéos de ces rassemblements
ont déclenché l'indignation dans tout le
pays
choqué le gouvernement a appelé ce lundi
les espagnols à faire preuve de
responsabilité
nous espérons que les gens seront très
prudent et comprendront que s'ils ont
vécu au moment de relâchement
un moment durant lequel ils ont pu faire
ce qu'il voulait s'ils doivent
maintenant passer à un autre moment où
ils doivent contrôler quelle personne il
fréquente la façon dont il les fréquente
et qu'ils appliquent les gestes
barrières que chacun peut appliquer de
la meilleure façon possible
je reste confiant dans le milieu médical
ces images avaient encore du mal à
passer ce mardi
ce médecin en unité de soins intensifs
dans un hôpital de madrid ne digère pas
à ces images de liesse
alors même que la situation sanitaire
reste instable
ces gens ne savent ils pas ce qui se
passe dans les hôpitaux des gens de leur
âge moeurs évidemment je ressens de la
rage ce n'est pas sous contrôle nous
pouvons avoir une cinquième ou sixième
vague alors s'il vous plaît nous devons
garder la distanciation sociale à
laquelle nous sommes déjà habitués
porter un masque et minimiser les
rassemblements de masse absurde qui
peuvent être de nouveaux foyers de
contamination
les autorités espagnoles espère
désormais que ces célébrations ne
provoque pas un regain des cas de
contamination dans les prochaines
semaines malgré la fin de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
les régions peuvent demander à
rétablissement du couvre-feu
mais ils doivent obtenir le feu vert de
la justice pour l'appliquer c'est le cas
à valence ou dans l'archipel des
baléares où un couvre feu est maintenu
al'inverse les tribunaux locaux ont
rejeté le maintien de cette mesure dans
le pays basque espagnol ainsi que dans
les canaries